what would you say those two web series
did for your career The Guild and the
awkward black girl they just put me on
the map I believe in terms of exposure
even at that time I had just done
season two of awkward black girl I had
just done season six of the guild and
then I got a call from my commercial
agent at this point I did not have a
theatrical agent
and they said hey the casting director
arrested development is coming back and
the casting director wants to offer you
a small role and I said what how did
they even know about me I'm not
auditioning for TV shows or films right
now and they said they had been watching
web series and they just discovered me
so that was getting to do
an episode of Arrested Development was
really really special and and being on a
proper television set with hair and
makeup and craft services and them
picking up my outfit and being on set
with David Cross and Alia shocket that
was just
an experience that I will never forget
because I wasn't expecting it at the
time
would you say you're here now because of
those two series like has your life sort
of your career the trajectory of it
because of those series the timing was
right that it just brought other great
things into your life other roles oh
yeah I credit awkward black girl with
pretty much my entire career and and the
path that I personally chose to take
which is creating my own content and
putting my own stuff out there and
taking risks and not sitting by the
phone waiting for it to ring waiting for
my agent to call me
um almost with those calls when they do
come are like presents because I'm
continuing to make my own content and
then when my agent does call with
something I'm like oh that's cool that's
surprising and exciting so so I love
that about my life and definitely I
credit everything too
Awkward Black Girl
you talked about risk earlier waiting by
the phone and now you know that you can
take chances and a risk to create your
own work but even from a young age it
sounds like with the spelling bees
for however long that lasted that's a
risk that was definitely a risk
especially at that time I was a shy
introverted kid so to get up in front of
an audience I remember that moment
because when when you're in class of
eight and you're just doing the spelling
bee there's no audience it's just like
you get your word right or wrong and if
you get it wrong you just sit and you
become the audience and I was around my
friends so I do remember going to the
Regionals
and seeing that huge audience and that
probably scared me off as well so you
know what I'm just making excuses for
spelling the word radish
but anyway so it because I see you as
that you have a lot of you wouldn't be
fearful of of challenges but it seems
like you yeah I I'm not fearful of
challenges now I will say like I said I
was a shy introverted kid and then in
seventh grade when I switched to public
school and had all these friends I
looked in the mirror and I said to
myself I cannot be shy and introverted
anymore and then I just switched and
then I was getting kicked out of math
class because I was talking too much
there was a discussion on Twitter a few
weeks back about the film Community the
writing community and the wrong way and
the right way to do something
and I just wondered what your thoughts
are on that like
is there a wrong way to make a movie is
there a right way you know you talked
about over the course of the pandemic
you made watching movies sort of your
film school but there is a dogma of you
know this is the right way to do
something the right way to enter a scene
to end a scene do you feel that or
everyone should have their own unique
Style
I don't feel like there's a right or a
wrong way I think there are greats that
have come before us that we can learn a
lot from and they all have their own
Styles and if you're watching something
like David Lynch and Twin Peaks you
notice that he he tends to break the
rules and and go into melodrama which
was like the best part about Twin Peaks
I just I just loved it so much but then
you then you watch something like Good
Fellas and that feels like what
uh
a film buff would say is the right way
to make a movie but but I think I I just
love all kinds of movies and especially
if you watch International films if you
watch something that I'm really inspired
by is sethiji thrai who is a Bengali
filmmaker I'm also Bengali and he won an
honorary Oscar in the 80s or the 90s and
he what he did was he kind of broke off
well he didn't want to make Bollywood
type movies which is what Indian India
was known for at the time and he just
went into the villages and started
um focusing on women in The Villages and
and he would write these amazing stories
about
just regular women and what they were
going through and and it wasn't about
being rich and it wasn't about Musical
dance numbers and and it was just like a
quiet story and so what I believe is
there's not a right or wrong way to do
or create art and I think what's
exciting to me is
when you do get out of those boxes and
and we were talking about risk when you
take a risk and and maybe it doesn't pan
out the way that you wanted to in this
project then you don't do it again in
the next one you take a different kind
of risk and I love when
projects surprise me I love it when they
go a certain way or do a certain thing
that I'm not expecting and that's what's
exciting to me about art which movies
and TV shows fall into as well has
anyone said that to you like this should
be more this if you if you do it more
this way it'll have more marketability
I believe that happens more in the
screenwriting process and not really in
the filmmaking process
I I get notes from my scripts and my
pitches and honestly most of the time
the notes are make the project better so
it allows me to think about the project
in a different way that I may not have
seen before and and that's what's really
exciting sometimes what happens is
you'll go through like a circle of notes
taking you back to that same place where
you started but now you're more clear
about why you started with that story so
it's I appreciate notes I love getting
very hard critical notes on my work and
and I won't necessarily take 100 of the
notes but each note allows me to think
about the scene or my characters or the
work in a different way so I'm like okay
where is this now coming from what is
the person not attached
onto what what are they not getting in
this part and that's where the actual
note is coming from so getting notes to
me is very very awesome because
generally every time I've gotten notes
and I've done the rewrite it's a better
script than what I had written before
did anybody give you notes with
definition please like can you make it
go more in this direction and then we'll
have more marketability for it because
it's really just a story about you know
coming being a young person whether you
want to leave the nest or stay in your
small town it doesn't have to be
Bollywood it was just an experience that
happened to be different cultures that
all came together and knew each other
from high school yeah I got the I got
one note that I got
I believe it was during the script
process was
someone needs to die like it needs to be
in this climax moment like one of the
family members needs to die and I was
like
I don't think so I don't think that
needs to happen I'm really just trying
to you know make it a slice of life and
um this could be any family it just
happens to be a South Asian American
family in the center of it all and
that's what was exciting to me just to
show
Indian Americans as normal people just
like everyone else
I think mostly when I when I soft
pitched it around to production
companies that I already had
relationships with they all said that it
was too small of a film for them to take
on without really giving me any notes in
terms of like oh if you made it like
this maybe we could we could shoot it
but uh I understood that pass or that
you know that rejection per se because
because it is a small film
and it's about you know there's no
explosions and there's no you know big
special effects or anything so it's not
one of the five Studio films that that
you know a big Studio would make
um but I I wanted to make this for
myself just to
just to get a story out there that I had
never seen before on screen
do you see that ever though in the film
industry or you know with with film and
TV writing screenwriting that there's
there's definite like this is the wrong
way this is the right way I think there
is definitely a formula to telling big
budget films so if you're writing a big
budget film for a studio then there is
absolutely a correct way to do that and
uh I don't know if you guys have read
Thomas Lennon's book called how to write
movies and make profit how to make
movies how to make movies for fun and
for Fun and Profit and fun is crossed
out and one of the first one of the
first things that he says in the book is
if you're making a movie for Sundance
you need to put this book down
and gives really explicit instructions
on how to write
and create a studio film and I just love
the book because I have applied it to my
indie films that aren't necessarily
Studio films but but it's also a really
easy read and it's funny and it's fun to
get through and it's awesome to hear his
experiences and stories as a studio
screenwriter as opposed to me who's
who's writing for indie films but but
yes I do believe that there is a correct
way to write a studio film with certain
beats and certain explosions in certain
moments that happen between the stars of
the film that you have to have in there
or also Stars won't do the film